[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
39 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc Campoy, and I'm
here with my colleague, not
Mark Mandel.
Who are you?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Hi, I'm Chris.
You might remember me from such
shows as episode 33, I think.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
The one about Go,
I don't know which one it was.
Let me see, Chris.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Anyway, I'm the
token Australian on the show.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
whenever Mark is not here,
we replaced him with
another Australian.
So we had episode 25.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh, 25.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, episode 25
with Andrew Gerrand
and Chris Broadfoot.
Way too many
Australians that time.
This time there's only one.
So yeah, Mark is still
traveling somewhere in Australia
enjoying the holidays,
so instead we have Chris.
And we're going to be talking
today about PHP with Chris
but also with two other
coworkers, Terry Ryan and Brent
Shaffer.
And then after that,
once we're done
discussing all the
possible things you
can do with PHP on
Google Cloud Platform,
we will have a
question of the week.
And the question of the week
this week is about networking.
So the question
is, OK, so I want
to use WebSockets
on a load balancer,
and I'm using an HTTPS loads
balancer, how do I do that?
And so we'll have an answer for
that at the end of the episode.
But before that,
we're going to have
the cool thing of the week.
And the cool thing of the week
is about preemptible machines,
preemptible VMs.
Why don't you tell us
little bit about that?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: All
right, so this week we
announced that we're dropping
prices for preemptible VMs
by up to 33%.
Yeah, so this is really great.
I haven't really used
preemptible VMs very much.
But after reading this, I'm
kind of excited about it again.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: They're
very good, especially--
so basically the
preemptible machine,
a preemptible VM is a VM that
can be preempted, obviously,
and has a limit that it
cannot run more than 24 hours.
So regardless of what
happens after 24 hours,
it will be shut down.
But it could be shut
down faster than that.
But you have the power
to react to that.
There is actually
an API call that
is done before it's shut down.
So you can shut down gracefully
if you need to release
some resources or whatever.
You can toy with that.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It's
really great for anything
like batch work
or some processing
or something like that.
Maybe you're processing logs
every six hours or something
like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, so if you're
running anything
MapReduce style,
like Spark, Hadoop, or whatever,
or if you're doing things
like batch work-- like we know
we have ZYNC, for instance.
They use it to render movies.
Rendering a movie takes
a lot of computation time
but it is not something
urgent, so it makes it much,
much more affordable to do
it with preemptible machines,
especially now.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And even though
these prices have dropped 33%,
they're already much, much
cheaper than the regular VMs.
So it really pays off to
write these kind of jobs
in a way that are robust.
So if the machine
goes down, your code
doesn't really have to
worry about that very much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I mean, you
should be writing your code
like that anyway.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Yeah, definitely.
I mean, things
just happen, right?
Maybe network links go
down or a data center
catches on fire or
something like that.
Like, machines just
go away sometimes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, but yeah,
if your application is already
designed that way, check it out.
We have a link to the block
first announcing the new prices
on the show notes, as usual.
Cool, so I think that
it's time to go talk
with our friends,
Terry and Brent.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Great.
Let's talk PHP.
So we're very excited to have
here today our two coworkers,
Terry Ryan and Brent Shaffer.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Hey, how's it going?
BRENT SHAFFER: It's going great.
How are you guys?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very
happy to have you.
So yeah, very happy to
have you because you're
the only two people that
I know that like PHP.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Do
you mean at Google?
TERRY RYAN: You're just
not asking many people.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
at Google, in general.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK.
I know lots of
people that like PHP.
BRENT SHAFFER: Yeah, we're
not very well represented
at Google.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
there's not that many.
So I think it is
important to have you're
represented on the podcast.
So before we start
talking about PHP
and how awesome
it is, or not, why
don't you tell us a
little bit about who you
are, what do you do at Google?
Terry?
TERRY RYAN: Sure.
So like Francesc,
I'm on the DA team.
I go out and talk to
developers, I specifically
spend a lot of time with the PHP
community, going to PHP events
and trying to get out the
message that we at Google have
PHP solutions on
Google Cloud Platform.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Could you tell us
a little bit more
about your experience with PHP?
I think you used to do a lot of
PHP before joining Google, too?
TERRY RYAN: Yeah, so
before I worked for Google,
I worked for Adobe.
And all of the web work I
did at Adobe was all PHP.
And then before that, I spent
some time at the Wharton School
at the University
of Pennsylvania
and a lot of our public
stuff was PHP, in addition to
other languages.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
What about you, Brent?
BRENT SHAFFER: Yeah, hi,
so I'm a DPE like Chris.
And that means that
I'm an engineer,
but I'm more on the
side of our end users.
So I spend a lot
of time on GitHub.
And I do a lot of work
integrating with our platform
and trying to make that process
easier for the developers that
are using our products.
So specifically,
I've been working
on a lot of the PHP libraries
that we have on GitHub.
And historically, I
have a PHP background,
which is one of the reasons
why I was picked for this role,
and I actually do like PHP.
Whenever I started
developing PHP,
it was the first dynamic
language that I had used.
Previously I'd been programming
in Java and C Sharp,
so I loved it.
And I was also fortunate
enough to learn
from some developers that
actually had good coding
practices and standards.
And so I started learning on
the Symfony Framework, which
those guys are really,
really solid developers.
And so I was luckily able to
fall into the part of the PHP
community that has really,
really solid developers
and programming practices.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So everything I know about PHP
on Google Cloud Platform is
basically what you can find
on cloudgoogle.com/php.
Why don't you tell
us a little bit
about-- so yeah, if
I was a PHP developer
and I get to go Google
Cloud Platform, what
do we have at my disposal?
TERRY RYAN: Well, we
have the wide range
of all of Google Cloud Platform,
but specifically focused
on computing resources, it would
be App Engine, Compute Engine,
and Container Engine.
For App Engine, PHP is one of
those standard languages that
runs on App Engine standard,
which means that you can take
PHP code that you use in
other places, plop it down,
and it will run right within
the context of App Engine
relatively easily.
Of all the languages
that imported code
over from non-App
Engine to App Engine,
I feel like the PHP implantation
is the lightest in terms
of what you have to change.
You have to change a couple
places where you point
to the file system, because
on App Engine, you can't.
But you get rid of those
calls and for the most part,
a lot of your PHP code
is just going to work,
it's really kind of fantastic.
So we've got App Engine
standard and we also
have App Engine
flexible runtime,
PHP is supported
on both of those,
in addition to Compute
Engine and Container Engine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So for PHP standard
environment in App Engine,
can you use any
kind of framework?
Like you were talking
about Symfony,
is that something that
developers can just
use directly?
BRENT SHAFFER: That's
a good question.
So we do support some
of the larger frameworks
out there, like for instance,
WordPress runs really
well on App Edition
standard because we've
put a lot of effort into making
that an easy process to get up
and running.
We also have some documentation.
We're getting Symfony
up and running.
So there are a lot of
restrictions in App Engine
classic because it's a sandbox
environment, so anybody that's
using another
framework out there,
there's quite a few
with PHP, it's not
like the Ruby community where
they've all kind of agreed
on one or two
frameworks, there's just
a ton of PHP frameworks.
So yeah, we don't have tutorials
out there for every single one,
but I think it is worth
trying to deploy in App Engine
standard.
We have a lot of
good documentation
on what is and isn't supported
for App Engine standard PHP
runtime.
So for instance, if you know
you need a certain extension,
you should check
the documentation
and if it's not available
in App Engine standard,
then you want to run that
framework in App Engine
flexible environment.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Can
you give some examples
of things that might not work?
TERRY RYAN: Well for
the longest time,
ImageMagick wasn't supported
but we now support that,
so that's gone away
and it's not a problem.
We did, in the last big
rev of PHP on App Engine,
fix a lot of the most requested
things that were missing.
I don't know off the
top of my head something
that would be-- it
would be something
that-- a not widely used tool.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So the
majority of applications
will run just fine?
BRENT SHAFFER: Well
yeah, and there's
a lot of frameworks that require
the file system by default
out of the box.
So I guess it's
more like, it's not
a question of whether it
will run in App Engine,
it's a question of
how much work would
be required to get
it to the point
where it would
run on App Engine.
And that varies per framework.
So for instance, the WordPress
and the Symfony tutorials
we have, we've gone
ahead and we've
made sure we take care of
that kind of stuff for you.
But for Laravel,
for CakePHP, we're
still working on getting
those solutions out there
so you don't have
to do it yourselves.
And for somebody that's
new to the platform, that
deploys one of these
frameworks, that
might be a frustrating
process at first,
trying to tweak the knobs of
the framework to get it to run.
TERRY RYAN: I was going to
say, the big thing that I've
run into is, as you point out,
that they need the file system.
And I find, they
need the file system
to write a configuration.
However, once that
configuration file is written,
it doesn't actively edit
that configuration every time
the app runs, it's
like a one time thing.
And so if you can get them
set correctly in development
and pushed to production,
you typically are OK.
That's been my experience
with the couple of frameworks
that I've experimented with.
And not some of the
bigger ones, like Lumen
and those types of frameworks.
BRENT SHAFFER: Yeah, so I've
found that the frameworks that
generate configuration for
their production environment,
it's very difficult to get
them to generate correctly
in a dev environment.
And so what I've typically done
is use Google Cloud Storage
as a file system.
And because you have a stream
wrapper, so instead of saying,
these files are going to be
written to cache/templates,
you just say, these files
are going to be written
to gs://bucketname/cache.
And then it all will
actually function as you
would expect it to function.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And so I guess
that would be a shared cache
as well, across someone's-- So
what's the best way for someone
to get started and to use
Cloud storage for that?
BRENT SHAFFER: Well
they could look
at the Symfony starter project.
We have, the stream wrappers
being used as a shared
cache in that project.
The WordPress, there's
a get help repository
that we have all of these
framework samples in.
There's a WordPress one
that does the same thing.
So yeah, there's a couple
examples of us doing that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So of these restrictions
that we're talking about,
they are related to a App
Engine standard environment?
Do we have any problem
running your PHP
on flexible environment?
BRENT SHAFFER: Yeah, so
we've been working really
hard on the App Engine
flexible runtime
for PHP and that's something
that builds in docker
and so it's really portable
and it's really great.
You can run it in
Kubernetes cluster
and we have some
pretty cool docs
on how to do that, also
running microservices
and multiple services
that are communicating
with each other in Kubernetes
cluster and also in App Engine
flexible.
Because since App
Engine flexible runs
docker container images, they're
all compatible, which is nice.
That runtime is on GitHub
and it's in the repository
googlecloudplatform/php-docker.
But it is almost an alpha.
So we have a lot of docs,
we have a lot of stuff
and we're putting a lot of
time into making it good,
but I think it's important to
note it's not quite in alpha.
TERRY RYAN: It's almost alpha.
BRENT SHAFFER: Maybe by
the time this goes live,
it will be an alpha.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Yeah, no, this is
coming out next week.
So I don't know
how fast you are,
but that is a challenge now.
Cool.
So you mentioned Kubernetes.
That is actually something
that our audience loves.
We keep on talking about
Kubernetes and Google Container
Engine basically every
episode, more or less.
How is the experience?
I know a lot of people that
come to PHP because of the LAMP
stack.
That P in the lamp
is PHP or Python,
apparently, according to
what I just read, surprising.
But yeah, so if I come
from LAMP stack, what
is the best place to run it?
Could it be standard App Engine?
Could it be flexible App Engine?
Could it be Container
Engine, Compute Engine?
TERRY RYAN: I think the
answer is going to depend.
So if you're running
a LAMP stack box,
the first thing you got to say
is, like, that's really bad.
Don't do that anymore.
But for whatever
reason, your friend
set it up, not you,
your friend set it up
and now you are
responsible for it.
So we have, in Compute
Engine, LAMP stack images
in Cloud Launcher.
So you want to get
started on LAMP?
Boom, you just run it on Cloud
Launcher, and you're there.
What is the best way to do it?
It's going to depend.
If you are moving towards
a containerized workload,
then I would definitely tell
you to look at Kubernetes
and Container Engine and
splitting it up that way,
with the caveat that
the M is going to be
the problematic part of that.
Kubernetes and containers
and persistent database,
it's not always a good combo.
And then you're trading in
one disaster for another.
So I would say, look
at getting-- hey,
you have a lot of
options, you can
go App Engine, either standard
or flexible, running Cloud SQL,
and that solves a lot
of problems for you.
You can go with
Kubernetes and Cloud SQL
or you can run your full My
SQL on Kubernetes as a pet,
I would not recommend
that, I would say,
go without Cloud
SQL for the M part.
And then, it's going to depend.
Are you moving containers?
Then the Container
Engine would probably
be the best place
for you to look.
Are you anticipating
incredible amounts of scale
or incredibly variable
amounts of scale
where App Engine really shines?
Well, then obviously,
I'd go App Engine.
Let's go with the full
flow diagram here.
If you're in that
scenario and you
need to run bits that won't
run on App Engine standard
for whatever reason,
then flexible
is probably what you want
to do with the caveat
that it is currently pre-alpha.
We don't even have
a name for it.
So I mean, I would go through
the whole explanation,
and that's how I'd talk
to a customer about it
if they were interested.
BRENT SHAFFER: Yeah, I think if
you have an existing app that's
pretty sizable, using a
GC instance, just a VM
and possibly using
the LAMP deployment
is going to be the easiest way
to get your app up and running.
But if you're coming at it
with a fresh application,
I would definitely encourage
containerizing first
with flexible, because it's
such an easy move from flex
to Kubernetes.
And so if you think you may
require scale eventually,
it's a really nice
way to go, not
to mention just
the portability you
get from containers
and images, is really
nice as a software engineer.
TERRY RYAN: And one
of the things that's
come up when I've talked about
Kubernetes is that idea of,
so you have the LAMP
stack, and the code is all
looking at itself, looking
at everything as level host.
But one of the great
things about Kubernetes
is that you can run multiple
containers in the same pod
as offering a local host.
And that is, there's a nice
bridging stepping stone
towards getting to a
better place with your app,
is moving into Kubernetes and
taking advantage of the fact
that you containerize
it but also leave
the code non-containerized.
Not ideal, but most of these
are bridging solutions anyway.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: What's
the best way for someone
to use something like
Engine X as a proxy?
BRENT SHAFFER: I
was actually trying
to work this in
the conversation,
so we don't have a LAMP stack,
but we do have more or less
a LEMP stack, right?
It's on Flex.
Yeah, so Flex uses Engine X.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Francesc
and I are trying to decode.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Are you
just talking about the names?
TERRY RYAN: Engine
X instead of Apache.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Yeah, it's the E.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: How
do you pronounce that?
BRENT SHAFFER: I realize the
nuances in the pronunciation
might have been lost.
"lahmp" and "leemp,"
I don't know.
Yeah, so we use Engine
X. And then the M,
Cloud SQL works exactly
like a MySQL instance
so it integrates perfectly.
TERRY RYAN: Just
to disambiguize,
that's on the App
Engine flexible runtime.
When I said earlier
about Cloud Launcher,
we do have full on LAMP stack
boxes in Cloud Launcher.
Just getting all out
acronyms in a row.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
actually curious about,
when you have the
Cloud Launcher,
do we also have things that
depend directly on Cloud SQL,
or do they all start
one instance, which
is like the SQL instance?
TERRY RYAN: As far as
I know, none of them
point to Cloud SQL as
their SQL solution.
It doesn't mean you can't.
It just means that out
of the box, they don't.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Just need
to configure it a little bit.
Cool.
Yeah, I think that is something
that most people, regardless
of if they do PHP
or not, they should
consider is running your own SQL
databases, consider Cloud SQL.
Version two is so much better,
it is very fast and it scales.
You can actually make the
disk bigger, which is magic.
That is amazing.
You don't need to migrate
and have weird moments where
you need to make your
database read-only,
so you can migrate
to something else.
It just works.
TERRY RYAN: It's easy
to set up replicas,
it's easy to set up
Nearline backups.
Cloud SQL V2 is magic, with the
caveat that it is not yet GA.
BRENT SHAFFER: Pre-alpha.
TERRY RYAN: It's still not GA.
I mean, it's been running a long
time, and it's really stable,
and it's all these great things.
But if you are a company
or you need an SLA,
we don't have an SLA on it.
So it's one thing,
but if you look,
it's very clear from
the UI flow, right?
You go to it, and
it's like, try V2,
or there's this
Cloud One down there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Down
there at the bottom.
You need to scroll.
Yeah.
TERRY RYAN: So we
definitely, I think,
want to push people
to V2, but make
sure that people understand
that the SLA is not there yet.
BRENT SHAFFER: And
how about Postgres?
Is that a big thing
in the PHP community?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: No,
I don't think so.
TERRY RYAN: Bigger in
the Ruby community.
BRENT SHAFFER: And we do
have click to deploy Postgres
instances.
And PDO, the database
abstraction library for PHP,
supports Postgres, too,
so it's definitely there
if people want to use it.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Great.
And so other than running
apps, what else is new,
in terms of PHP, on Cloud?
BRENT SHAFFER: Well,
so we are working
on a pretty nice
library that people can
use to access the Cloud APIs.
And again, one of the great
things about the PHP space
is it's rapidly developing
and it's getting better.
Unfortunately, that means that
a lot of the stuff we're talking
about is still in pre-alpha
slash not GA states,
but one of those things
is our Cloud library.
And we have a lot of
really nice APIs, really
nice wrappers for
APIs, that you can
use to manage Pub/Sub,
BigQuery, data store, everything
pretty much.
TERRY RYAN: And the new
library, like the vision API.
BRENT SHAFFER: Vision
is in there, yeah.
Natural language
API is in there.
I mean, pretty much every cloud
API has a wrapper in PHP now,
and they're all really,
really nice to use
and really easy to understand
compared to the previous stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So are
those wrappers wrapping--
which API are they wrapping?
Are they wrapping the
REST API or the GRPC API?
BRENT SHAFFER:
Yeah, good question.
So they're wrapping
the REST API right now,
but GRPC support is
definitely planned.
It's scheduled for before
the end of the year,
so it should have both.
And then that will be able to
multiplex on one or the other,
depending on if you have the
GRPC extension installed.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And
speaking of GRPC, what's
the state of that in PHP?
BRENT SHAFFER: Yeah,
so it's supported.
Again, to Google
investing in PHP,
you can use PECL, which is
the PHP Extension Manager.
So if you do PECL
installed GRPC,
it will compile the C extension.
And then once you have that,
you enable that C extension,
and then you can use GRPC.
TERRY RYAN: And that's on
PHP on Compute Engine, right?
BRENT SHAFFER: You can do
that in Compute Engine, yeah.
TERRY RYAN: Can you do
it on App Engine as well?
I haven't tried it yet,
so I was just curious.
BRENT SHAFFER: So
you could definitely
do it with a custom runtime.
We are going to build GRPC
into the supported runtime
at some point, for sure.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we are kind of
running out of time.
Is there any other
topic that you'd like
to discuss before we finish?
BRENT SHAFFER: So I had one.
I just wanted to mention,
one of the things
that's really nice about
using the runtimes that we're
trying to provide
is we're trying
to tackle the misconception that
PHP is not a secure language.
So we're spending a lot of
time making the runtime secure
by default. And
that means, we've
done things like we've patched
core PHP functions that
might have some really unsafe
operations and properties.
One instance of that is,
there's like the par string
function that people use
to parse query strings.
It can be used
improperly in a way that
would override global variables,
and then thus be a really,
really large threat factor.
And so we've patched
PHP to not allow that.
There's also
security extensions.
One is called
SUHOSIN that we use.
And that does the same
thing, of black listing a lot
of the functions that are
traditionally abused in PHP,
and you can still use them.
You can white list them
by setting an environment
variable, but they are secured.
They are locked down by default.
So there's a couple other
things we do in that same vein.
One of them kind of
being using Engine X
and trying to do the things
that maybe aren't as largely
accepted in the PHP community
as they are in other language
communities.
And so we're trying to bring
those to PHP developers
without them having to
opt in or whatever else.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
What about you, Terry,
is there anything else
that you would like to mention?
TERRY RYAN: Well,
the only think I'd
mention is that Bernstein does
a lot of work on the APIs.
And one of things
I really appreciate
about them is that they're
very clearly written
by people that write PHP
and not like, oh, here's
the Python
implementation in PHP.
That's all on
GitHub, and I don't
know how accepting of outside
input are we with them.
BRENT SHAFFER: Oh, definitely.
Any contributions, we're like
super, super excited about.
TERRY RYAN: Yeah, so
if anybody's out there
and they're fooling
around with these things
and find either a--
not that there would
be a problem, right, Brent?
But you know, we're developers,
and we know how it goes.
So we would definitely
welcome any contributions.
BRENT SHAFFER: Yeah, and all
this stuff is at a early stage.
So there's a couple of guys
that have given us suggestions,
and their input goes a long
way because we are still
making a lot of
decisions on how we're
going to move forward with these
runtimes and all this stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So one last question.
What is the best place
for a PHP developers
to start using Google
Cloud Platform?
BRENT SHAFFER:
Cloud.google.com/php.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Easy.
So thank you very
much to you two
for taking the time today
to talk to us about PHP
and everything you can do
on Google Cloud Platform.
BRENT SHAFFER: Yeah,
thanks so much.
TERRY RYAN: Woo!
Go PHP!
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Thanks
again to Terry and Brent.
That was really great.
I learned a lot about PHP.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I
didn't know much about PHP,
but I almost want to
try it now-- almost.
Almost there, yeah.
Cool, so it's time to go with
our question of the week.
And the question of
the week this week
is something that
I'm not a master on.
As I've said many times, I'm
not a network expert at all.
But it is something that
is pretty interesting.
So we have the
HTTPS load balancer,
which is a load balancer
that works globally.
So basically it does
routing, and it sends
for whatever requests you get.
For an HTTP request,
you'll be able to send it
to the closest instance
group that you have running.
So yeah, so if you send a
request coming from Barcelona,
for instance, it will
go through the center
that we have in Belgium.
But if you send it
from San Francisco,
it could go to the new data
center in the West Coast.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oregon, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But
it has a restriction,
which is, it doesn't
support WebSockets.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Right.
And this is because
WebSockets aren't HTTP.
They are its own protocol,
which is somewhat
related to HTTP but
only in a little way.
So it's kind of expected
that the HTTP load
balancer doesn't work with it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it is really not HTTP.
It's more like TCP with
some HTTP sprinkled on top.
So the question is, OK,
so since these are not
supported, what do I do if
I want to have WebSockets
on our global load balancer?
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Yeah, you certainly
want some load
balancing, because it's
quite an expensive protocol.
So the solution is to
use the SSL load balancer
if you're using SSL
with your WebSockets,
and I do recommend that.
And if you're not, then you can
also use the TCP load balancer.
And so this is just a more
flexible load balancer
that doesn't really care about
high level protocols like HTTP.
So this could be used
for any sort of protocol
that happens over TCP.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So basically, if you move
to the TCP load balancer,
you will be losing the fact that
you have global load balancing,
because the TCP load
balancer is actually
regional, which in many
cases, actually, totally fine.
So if that's something that
you're fine with, then,
yeah, just use the
TCP load balancer,
and WebSockets are
completely supported.
But if not, we have this
different load balancer,
which is the SSL load balancer,
that manages SSL, obviously.
That is the name.
But also, it does routing
across different regions.
So again, if a WebSocket
started from Barcelona,
it would go to Belgium, but
if it goes from San Francisco,
you'd go to, I think it's Oregon
or something, like West Coast.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And
I guess that's pretty
important for WebSockets
because they're usually
like low latency kind
of thing, maybe a game,
like an interactive
real-time game or something.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: If
you're using WebSockets,
you're basically
trying to do real time.
So if you end up in a
different continent,
yeah, the real times aren't
going to be that real.
So yeah, so check
it out, so we're
going to have links
from the show notes
to all the documentation
to both the TCP load
balancer, the HTTPS
load balancer,
and then finally, the
SSL load balancer.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And all
of the PHP stuff, too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And all
the PHP stuff, lots of links
from there, too.
Well, thank you so much, Chris,
for taking the time this week
to record this amazing
episode with me.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It was
good being Mark for a day.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it was good to keep
on having an Australian
accent next to me.
It makes me feel like home.
So yeah, again,
thank you so much,
and thank you so much to all
the listeners for being there.
And talk to you all next week.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK, thanks.
I won't see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]